and just to the south a leftist judge in
west virginia has just tossed a
republican candidate from the ballot
even though early voting is already
underway and the primary is just days
away
kanawha circuit court judge duke bloom
ruled that votes for a district senate
candidate andrea garrett
andrew garrett kiesling would not be
counted
due to issues over her residency
now immediately signs were posted at
polling places announcing that she is
ineligible
but andrea kiesling is fighting back
saying she always
has been a west virginian and that this
is disenfranchising to the voters the
candidate made an appeal to the supreme
court to put a stay on judge bloom's
ruling and hours ago
they rejected
that uh that motion joining us now is
gop state senate candidate andrew
garrett kiesling and her campaign
adviser greg thomas
andrea
okay your your appeal was rejected for
the stay
voting is underway
where does your fight possibly go from
here
yeah well thanks for having us on lara
of course we are very disappointed by
the supreme court's ruling today um
it's just uh it's it's disappointing we
we have a lot of expectations in terms
of the integrity of elections and the
fact that there was a judge that was
interfered with our elections is
concerning there was a window to contest
eligibility of candidates and that
window passed nearly three months ago
so what's going on i mean you have a
campaign manager sitting next to you who
you know would anticipate you would
anticipate everything right you as a
campaign manager you have to
okay this this roadblock could come this
obstacle could come
but when the voting is already underway
how is this in any way obvious common
sense fair forget the legal issues that
are involved
yeah i mean i think that's exactly it
laura we you know obviously we knew the
you know she cut
andrea had split time between here and
another state uh over a few years but
you know there's a window to challenge
this stuff uh once we got through that
window you know we really uh you know
stepped on the gas on the campaign uh
and and what triggered this challenge as
we have one of her opponents in the
primary a very liberal candidate named
josh higginbotham he was the only
republican to support the transgender
issue
kind of stuff here in west virginia
once he took a poll and found out that
andrea was in first and he was in last
uh then he that he he buddied up with
the local uh you know greedy personal
injury lawyers and the local liberal
activist judge and you know got her
thrown off the ballot
but that you got a state supreme court
refusal to intervene as well and and yet
when people are going to vote andrea is
your name on the ballot any longer or no
my name is on the ballot it's it's still
there there are signs in some precincts
that have indicated that at my
ineligibility um but my name's still on
the ballot and i'm still many people
have reached out and let me know that
they're still going to be voting for me
well what happens if you actually get
the most votes
they just they're going to throw that
out too i guess right greg
yeah yeah essentially they just uh the
judge the judge ruled the judge ruled
that they won't count her votes so
they'll be you know she uh the most
recent polling we have she was getting
over 50 percent uh in a four-way race
and so
essentially the minority of voters will
be
you know split you know the majority of
the minority of voters will you know get
to pick you know some liberal republican
to get beat by the democrat in the fall
so andrea
the concern was that you were what and
you were
resident in two different states
or you spent too much time in another
state to be eligible is that it
correct i i had moved to north carolina
and spent some time there i split my
time between north carolina minnesota
and west virginia in the pursuit of
businesses and other opportunities
and yeah that that came down that came
down to be the the biggest problem uh
now of course in west virginia one of
our main concerns is retention of talent
and that's something that we want to do
is bring people back to west virginia uh
my my time spent in other states was
simply a means to an end to be able to
return to west virginia so of course i'm
i'm disappointed but you know there's
still there's still a lot of work to do
well andrea and greg both of you first
of all thanks for coming but andrea
you just have to get back at it okay
don't don't let this stop you okay
they're going to keep trying to do stuff
like this i imagine but you have to run
again if this doesn't uh pan out which
looks like it might not but thank you
for alerting us to all of these
developments in west virginia hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else